Based on our coverage tracker, we can now compare the coverage for different inputs.
I'm going to use the input foo without markup, as we've just seen it,
I'm going to use foo with HTML markup,
and I'm going to use the same enclosed in double quotes.
Let's first start with foo as we've just seen it.
Here the tag line is being executed,
initialization of code, initialization of out is being executed.
We have the loop, overall characters, we have the 1st condition,
we have the 2nd condition,
and we have the 3rd condition.
As we've seen before, none of these conditions evaluates to true
for any of the characters in foo.
Instead, only adding characters to out is being executed.
The assertion, finally, passes.
Now let's see what this looks like for foo with markup.
Again, the initialization is carried out
for this input as well, as is the loop.
However, here this condition immediately becomes true already on the 1st character,
so tag is being set to true too.
At the end of the tag, tag is being set to false again.
We also check this condition,
but since we don't have any quotes in there, this line is never executed,
and, of course, we add individual characters.
The assertion in the end passes.
Now let's come to our input which should trigger a failure.
That is, the same thing as before but now enclosed in double quotes.
Again, all of this is executed, no way to avoid this.
The 1st thing that happens in here is that quote is being set
over here with the 1st character.
And since quote is being set, these 2 conditions never hold.
And everything, including the tag characters up here,
is being added to the output.
Since the markup characters are being added,
the assertion finally fails.
If you look at the coverage up here,
you find that there is one line in the program
whose execution correlates with failure.
And this is precisely this line, namely, quote = not quote.
This line is only executed in the failing run.
So all we need in this situation is to look at the governing condition,
and lo and behold, we do have a defect.
Ha! That was easy, wasn't it?
Unfortunately, things are not always that easy.